>> President Trump: WE HAD A
GREAT MEETING, ALL OF THE
REPUBLICAN SENATORS WERE THERE
AND WE MADE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS
ON A LOT OF ISSUES.
WE HAVE SOME POSITIVE THINGS
HAPPENING BOTH IN TERMS OF THE
COUNTRY AND IN TERMS OF THE
ELECTION THAT’S COMING UP.
>> Ed: PRESIDENT TRUMP RIGHT
THEREAFTER TO YESTERDAY’S
CLOSED-DOOR LAUNCH WITH SENATE
AND REPORTS INDICATING THAT HE’S
URGING LAWMAKERS WHO TOUGHEN UP
AGAINST THE DEMOCRATS.
MY NEXT GUEST WAS THERE FOR
LUNCH.
JOINING US NOW AS JOHN BARRASSO,
CHAIR OF THE SENATE REPUBLICAN
COMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, SENATOR.
SO WHAT WAS GOING ON BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS BECAUSE
KELLYANNE CONWAY TOLD US THE
PRESIDENT IS READY TO GET BACK
ON THE TRAIL AND TRANSITION BACK
TO SOME OF THOSE RALLIES MAY BE
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND WE WERE HEARING
THAT BEHIND CLOSED DOORS HE WAS
BOASTING ABOUT HIS POLL NUMBERS
AND BASICALLY SAYING LET’S TAKE
ON THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND
HE’S FEELING GOOD HEADING INTO
THIS ELECTION.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS VERY
POSITIVE AND OPTIMISTIC, FOCUSED
ON THE FUTURE AND GETTING PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK AND GETTING THE
COUNTRY OPEN AGAIN AND GETTING
THE DISEASE BEHIND US IN TERMS
OF THE SUCCESSES WE’VE HAD IT.
IT WAS A VERY POSITIVE MEETING,
FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON THE FUTURE
AND HE DID TALK ABOUT THE
UPCOMING ELECTIONS AND THE NEED
FOR US TO BE STRONG AND SMART
AND TOUGH AND FIGHTING THE
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT
THEY HAVE A TENDENCY TO WANT TO
DO.
WE SEE THEIR PLAYBOOK IN THE
NANCY PELOSI $3 TRILLION BIG --
I THINK TERRIBLE, BASICALLY
THEIR PLAYBOOK FOR 2020.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WHOLE LIST
OF THINGS THAT SHE IS OFFERING
AS BASICALLY A PLAYOFF TO THE
POLITICAL LEFT, THAT’S WHAT THIS
IS.
IT’S VERY PARTISAN AND IT’S NOT
FOCUSED ON GETTING OUR COUNTRY
OPEN AGAIN IN ANY SORT OF A
TARGETED OR TIMELY OR TEMPORARY
WAY.
>> Ed: I WANT TO GET TO THAT
STIMULUS IN JUST A LITTLE BIT.
QUICKLY ON THE POLITICS, THERE
HAVE BEEN SEVERAL REPORTS
SUGGESTING THAT YOU AND OTHER
SENATE REPUBLICANS ARE VERY
NERVOUS ABOUT THE PRESIDENT’S
REELECTION PROCESS AND THAT YOU
COULD LOSE CONTROL OF THE SENATE
IN NOVEMBER.
DID THAT COME BACK YESTERDAY AND
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU?
>> THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE SENATE
ARE THAT WE HAVE 23 REPUBLICANS
WHO ARE UP AND ONLY A DOZEN
DEMOCRATS SO ABSOLUTELY YOU HAVE
TO FOCUS ON THAT IN THE MARGIN
IS SLIM RIGHT NOW.
THE PRESIDENT WAS KEY TO POINT
OUT THAT IF THE DEMOCRATS TAKE
CONTROL OF THE SENATE, THAT
CHUCK SCHUMER WILL CHANGE THE
RULES ON DAY ONE TO MAKE IT
HARDER TO GET THINGS DONE IN THE
SECOND TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
WE KNOW THAT THE DEMOCRATS --
THEY CONTINUE TO ROADBLOCK THE
PRESIDENT’S APPOINTMENTS, WE
STILL HAVE OVER 100 APPOINTEES
IN YOUR NUMBER FOR THAT HAVEN’T
GONE THROUGH SO WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT NOT JUST DOES
PRESIDENT TRUMP GET REELECTED
BUT WE HOLD A SENATE REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO CONFIRM THE CONSERVATIVE
JUDGES AND WE HAVE DONE OVER 200
SO FAR.
>> Ed: WILL GUESS WHAT
SENATOR, WE HAVE A SOUND BITE
TEED UP FROM CHUCK SCHUMER AND
HE SAYS YOU ARE NOT FOCUSED
ENOUGH ON THE NEW STIMULUS BILL.
>> FOR THE THIRD WEEK IN A ROW
THAT THE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IN
THE SENATE HAS NO COVID RELATED
BUSINESS ON THE AGENDA.
THERE ARE NOW MORE THAN
35 MILLION AMERICANS OUT OF WORK
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
ALMOST 1.5 MILLION AMERICANS ARE
SICK.
NEARLY 90,000 HAVE DIED AND
SENATE REPUBLICANS HAVE DECIDED
TO TAKE THE MONTH OFF FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS.
>> Ed: I GOT IT, I KNOW YOU
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES BELIEVE
CHUCK SCHUMER WILL BE PARTISAN
ABOUT THIS BUT ON THE OTHER HAND
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES HAVE
BEEN OPEN ABOUT SAYING YOU WANT
TO TAKE A PAUSE.
CAN YOU REALLY PAUSE ON STIMULUS
WHEN OVER 35 OR 36 MILLION
PEOPLE ARE UNEMPLOYED RIGHT NOW?
>> AS YOU KNOW ONLY ABOUT HALF
OF THE MONEY YOU’VE ALREADY
APPROVED HAS GONE OUT.
THERE’S ANOTHER HUNDRED BILLION
FOR HOSPITALS AND MOTHER HUNDRED
BILLION AVAILABLE IN A PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PLAN.
THERE’S 10,050,000,000,000 THAT
HAS GONE TO THE STATES THAT HAS
NOT YET BEEN SPENT.
I THINK THEY NEED MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW THEY DO IT
BUT ANYTHING WE NEED TO DO IN
TERMS OF ADDITIONAL EFFORTS
NEEDS TO HAVE INCLUDED IN THAT
LEGISLATION LIABILITY PROTECTION
SO THERE ARE SMALL BUSINESSES.
THE MOM-AND-POP BUSINESSES
AROUND THE COUNTRY HAVE SOME
PROTECTION AGAINST THE SIOUX AND
SETTLE LAWYERS WHO ARE ALREADY
SHARPENING THEIR KNIVES TO GO
AFTER THEM.
SO WE MAY NEED ANOTHER BILL BUT
I WILL TELL YOU IN TERMS OF WHAT
SENATOR SCHUMER SAID.
THE COMMITTEE THAT I CHAIR, THE
ENVIRONMENT AND PUBLIC WORKS
COMMITTEE, WE JUST PASSED THE
MAJOR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TALKED TO ME
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE AND OUR
COMMITTEE HAS PASSED A HIGHWAY
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AND NOW JUST
IN THE LAST WEEK SO WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL FOR OUR DAMS
AND PORTS AND THAT PUTS PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK.
>> Ed: THE LAST 30 SECONDS
HECK WE HAVE, HE STARTED BY
GOING AFTER NANCY PELOSI’S PLAN
WHICH AS YOU KNOW INCLUDES
STIMULUS MONEY FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
HER PUSHBACK IS THESE WERE FOLKS
THAT WERE HERE ILLEGALLY BUT
THEY ARE PAYING TAXES INTO THE
SYSTEM.
HOW DO YOU FIX ALL THAT?
ARE YOU GOING TO BUY THAT THAT
THEY ARE PAYING THE SYSTEM OR
ARE YOU GOING TO SAY THEY ARE
HERE ILLEGALLY AND THEY ARE NOT
GETTING ANY MORE NEW MONEY?
>> I DISAGREE WITH NANCY PELOSI.
SHE’S ACTUALLY MAKING IT EASIER
FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO WORK
THAN SHE IS MAKING IT EASIER FOR
THE 36 MILLION AMERICANS OUT OF
WORK TO GET BACK ON THE JOB.
THOSE ARE THE PERVERSE
INCENTIVES THAT SHE HAS INCLUDED